so the world is facing unprecedented
problems we have a short-term crisis
which is an economic crisis of
substantial proportions and we have a
long-term fiscal problem the world is
facing which is that governments have a
tremendous burden of debt and the
question is what can we do about this
and so when we think about the short
term we need to be thinking about
creating jobs and in the long term we
need to think about addressing one of
the key issues for progress fiscal
problems which is low health and paying
for health care and improving the health
of our older populations and our our
council is working on genetic solutions
to this problem and what that means is
that if we can invest now we can create
opportunities for innovation in this
field and the promises that if we do it
right we'll be able to create a happier
healthier society and actually turns out
that when you do that it actually ends
up costing less money so if we're able
to achieve our ends and develop the new
model that we're looking for then we can
help contribute to solving both of these
problems simultaneous